a를 얻었을 때 Z의 상태는 화면에 표시된 식으로 주어져요. 이건 조금 전에 봤던
행렬을 정규화해서 얻은 것이고, 그 행렬을 a가 나타날 확률로 나누는 것과 같아요.
이건 확률이 0이 아닐 때만 의미가 있다는 점을 말해야겠어요. 그렇지 않으면 0으로 나누게 되니까요.
하지만 괜찮아요. 일어나지 않는 일들에 대해서는 신경 쓸 필요가 없거든요. 이
강의 부분에서는 Neymark 정리라고 알려진 측정에 관한 간단하지만 근본적인 정리를 다룰 거예요.
요약하면, 어떤 측정이든 화면의 그림이 제시하는 방식으로 구현될 수 있다는 거예요.
말로 표현하면, 시스템 X에 대한 주어진 일반적인 측정은 다음과 같이 구현될 수 있어요.
먼저 고전적인 상태들이 가능한 측정 결과들인 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템 Y를 도입해요. 측정 결과는 0부터 n-1까지 번호가 매겨져 있다고 가정하고요.
그 다음 쌍 YX에 유니터리 연산 U를 수행하고,
그 다음 Y에 표준 기저 측정을 수행해요. 그러면 기본적으로 모든 것이
결정돼요. U의 선택만 빼고요. 그리고 정리가 말하는 건 이 유니터리
연산 U를 다양한 결과의 확률이 항상 주어진 일반적인 측정과
일치하도록 선택하는 것이 실제로 가능하다는 거예요. 이제 Neymark 정리가 어떻게 증명되는지 살펴볼게요. 어렵지 않아요. 그냥
유니터리 연산 U에 대한 좋은 선택을 하고 그게 맞는지 확인하면 되거든요. 하지만 먼저 행렬 이론의
기본적인 사실이 필요해요. 어떤 양의 반정치 행렬 P에 대해서도 Q 제곱이 P와 같은
유일한 양의 반정치 행렬 Q가 항상 존재한다는 거예요. 일반적으로 제곱해서 P를 주는 행렬이 많을 수 있지만,
그중 양의 반정치인 것은 항상 딱 하나예요. 이 행렬을 나타내는 표기법은 P의 제곱근이고,
말로도 그렇게 불러요. 어떤 양의 반정치 행렬 P의 제곱근을 계산하고 싶다면,
P의 스펙트럼 분해를 먼저 계산하고 그 다음
각 고유값을 그 제곱근으로 바꾸면서 고유 벡터들은 그대로 두면 돼요. 고유값들은 모두 음이
아니니까 이게 의미가 있고, 얻는 행렬이 실제로 양의 반정치이고
P의 제곱이 된다는 걸 쉽게 알 수 있어요. 유일성은 다른 문제인데, 행렬에 대한 기본적인 사실들을 이용해서
증명하는 건 어렵지 않지만 이 강의에서 다소 벗어나는 내용이라 그 부분은
주어진 것으로 받아들이고 넘어갈게요. 이제 그 개념을 이해했으니, 작동하는 유니터리 연산 U를
쉽게 명시할 수 있어요. 화면에 표시된 패턴과 일치하는 어떤 유니터리 행렬이든 실제로
작동할 거예요. 처음 n개의 열은, X가 이전처럼 n개의 고전적인 상태를 가진다고 가정하면, 측정을 표현하는
행렬들의 제곱근을 서로 쌓아서 얻어요. 나머지 열들은 무엇이든 상관없어요.
전체 행렬이 유니터리인 한 어떻게 해도 달라지는 게 없어요.
참고로, 채널의 Kraus 표현과 Stein spring 표현 사이의 연결과 닮았다는 걸 눈치챘다면, 그건 우연이 아니에요.
실제로 여기 있는 건 그것의 특수한 경우인데, 우리의 Kraus 행렬들이 모두 양의
반정치라는 거예요. 확인해야 할 두 가지가 있어요. 첫 번째는 이 U의 선택이 실제로 작동하는지이고,
두 번째는 명시되지 않은 열들을 U가 유니터리가 되도록 선택할 수 있는지예요. 첫 번째부터 시작할게요.
시작하는 상태는 이래요. 아래 시스템 Y는 영 상태로 초기화되어 있고, 위쪽 시스템은
상태 ρ에서 시작해요. 그 다음 U를 수행하는데, U로 켤레를 취하는 거예요.
이걸 모두 블록 행렬로 표현할 수 있어요. 화면에 표시된 것처럼요. 왼쪽에 U, 오른쪽에 U 대거,
중간에 |0⟩⟨0|과 ρ의 텐서 곱이 있는데, 여기 있는 형태를 취해요. 왼쪽 위 모서리에 ρ가 있고
나머지는 모두 0이에요. 이 곱에 대해 잠시 생각해보면, U의 명시되지 않은 항목들이
전혀 중요하지 않다는 게 분명해요. 중간 행렬의 0 항목들에 항상 곱해지니까요.
그리고 곱셈을 진행하면 여기에 표시된
행렬을 블록 행렬로 얻게 돼요. 아니면 직접 표기법을 사용해서
이렇게 표현할 수도 있어요. 실제로 이 형태가 우리에게 더 편리하니까, 이
식에 집중해볼게요. 편의를 위해 이 행렬, 즉 밀도 행렬에
σ라는 이름을 붙일게요. 마지막 단계는 Y에 대한 표준 기저 측정이에요. 그러면 Y의 축소 상태를 계산해볼게요.
우리가 가진 식을 이용하면 쉬워요. 그냥 두 번째 텐서 인수에 해당하는 X를 추적(trace out)하면 되거든요.
그러면 어떤 주어진 결과 a가 나타날 확률은 a에 해당하는 대각 항목이에요.
이렇게 쓸 수 있고, PA의 제곱근 × ρ × PA의 제곱근의 트레이스와 같아요.
그리고 트레이스의 순환 성질에 의해 PA × ρ의 트레이스를 얻게 되는데,
이게 우리가 원했던 거예요. 그래서 다양한 결과들이 나타날 확률이 올바르고, 항상 처음에 시작했던
원래 측정과 일치해요. 확인해야 할 두 번째 것은
U의 명시되지 않은 열들을 U가 유니터리가 되도록 채워넣는 게 가능한지예요.
이건 측정을 표현하는 행렬들의 제곱근으로 이루어진 처음 n개의 열이 정규직교라는 사실로부터 따라와요.
이건 꽤 직접적으로 확인할 수 있어요. 관련 세부 사항은 화면에 있어요.
원한다면 잠시 영상을 멈추고 생각해보세요. 하지만 이전에 제안했던 것처럼,
이건 사실 이전 강의에서 접했던 것의 특수한 경우예요.
이게 지금까지의 증명이에요. 이 강의에서는 파괴적 측정에 집중했어요. 측정된 시스템의 측정 후
양자 상태에 대한 명세가 없다는 의미에서요. 반면 비파괴적 측정은
고전적인 측정 결과뿐만 아니라 측정된 시스템의 측정 후 양자 상태도 있어요.
앞으로 보게 되듯이 Neymark 정리와 자연스러운 연결이 있어요. 사실 비파괴적
측정을 수학적으로 공식화하는 방법이 여러 가지 있는데, Neymark 정리에서 직접 나오는
한 가지 공식화부터 시작할게요. 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치
행렬들의 모음으로 표현된 일반적인 측정, 즉 파괴적 측정을 고려해요. p0부터 pN-1까지요. 그러면 이걸